[Musique]
et on va plus loin avec à mes côtés il
va reporter de guerre indépendante
bonjour anne bonjour face à vos bruno
daroux chroniqueur internationale ici
même à france 24 on évoquera évidemment
comment y échapper bien sûr les attentes
la tante avant les obsèques les
funérailles c'est pour lundi prochain le
le 19 septembre d'elizabeth ii mais en
attendant et bien c'est une longue
procession très chorégraphié qui se
déroule actuellement au royaume uni où
une veillée funèbre doit avoir lieu dans
la cathédrale saint gilles d'un instant
à l'autre les quatre enfants de la reine
se recueilleront et vous pourrez donc
suivre avec nous ce moment qui là aussi
un s'inscrit dans et bien sûr cette
séquence qui a qui avait été prévu bien
sûr par le protocole cette partie se
déroule donc en écosse puisque c'est à
balmoral que la reine elisabeth s'était
éteinte jeudi dernier on en parlera dans
un instant mais d'abord retour sur
l'ukraine et le vent est il en train de
tourner dans la guerre en l'espace d'un
week-end kiev revendique à la reprise de
3000 kilomètres carrés de son territoire
à l'armée russe et vladimir poutine se
voit contesté chez lui à moscou dans sa
ville de saint pétersbourg par des
groupes d'élus qui réclame son départ on
y va oui oui des deux côtés c'est à dire
la en ukraine sur le front et en russie
il se passe des choses assez
intéressantes donc pour ce qui est du
front là il faut dire que c'est l'oeuvre
d'un général donc il ya celui qui
commande et agen de nos agents le
général than au ski mais il ya un autre
général c'est le commandant de l'armée
de terre le général sir ski qui est
celui grâce auquel si j'ai bien compris
la ville de kiev n'a pas été prise il ya
quelques mois vous en souvenez c'est lui
qui a inventé cette stratégie qui fait
que finalement on croyait que la contre
offensive tout le monde avait les yeux
tournés vers le sud et ça s'est passé
dans le nord dans le donbass alors les
images que l'on voit qu'ils sont tournés
par des citoyens craignent un des
villageois par des journalistes qui
accompagnent les militaires ukrainiens
ou par les militaires craignent eux
mêmes effectivement montre
la joie avec laquelle ils sont
accueillis sur place montrent aussi de
la tire ni cas comme on dit en russe
c'est à dire des blindés abandonnés et
c'est ce qui n'est pas forcément
confirmée par moscou mais ce qui
confirmait par moscou c'est quand même
non pas la débandade bien sûr ce n'est
absolument pas le mot qui a utilisé le
mot clé utilisé c'est le mot
regroupement
regroupement saillir moscou explique ce
qui se passe par un regroupement
militaires pour aller ailleurs et pour
ce qui est de ce qui se passe en russie
même ça c'est très très important mais
parce qu'on va voir un jour le faire
commenté bien sûr mais cette lettre des
députés municipaux alors là les députés
municipaux de lomonosov c'est un moscou
puisque à la fois d'ailleurs une fronde
amende à moscou et les à s'intéresser à
moi à moscou voilà ce qu'on voit cher
vladimir vladimirovitch la rhétorique
que vous et vos subordonnés utilisé a
longtemps été empreinte d'intolérance et
d'agressions croirait presque un langage
occidental ce qui a finalement replongé
notre pays dans l'ère de la guerre
froide la russie a recommencé à être
crainte et aillent nous vous demandons
de vous retirer de votre poste car vos
opinions sont désespérément dépassé et
entravent le développement de la russie
et surenchérit du côté cette fois de
saint pétersbourg dmitri palio gars qui
lui accuse vladimir poutine ni plus ni
moins que de haute trahison il invoque
l'article 93 de la constitution qui
prévoit que le parlement russe puisse
d'émettre le chef de l'état le conseil
du district municipal de smolninski y
est a décidé de faire appel aux députés
de la douma d'état pour porter des
accusations de trahison contre le
président poutine afin de le destituer
de ses fonctions en mai soit ils sont
marginaux ses élus non elise raphaël var
est le principal c'est que déjà lui
parle c'est à dire jusqu'à il ya
quelques jours en france était
absolument impossible et defacto on n'a
pas eu ce genre d'expression donc c'est
nouveau il faut le saluer il faut
l'observer il faut voir quelles sont les
réactions et puis il faut cesser de dire
que la russie tel un monolithe serait en
faveur de cette guerre le fêter c'est
qu'on ne sait pas vraiment en fait on
sait déjà pas mal de choses mais surtout
la sq on sait ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il
y à des officiels pas de premier rang
certes mais qui ose écrire cette lettre
ouverte à vladimir poutine donc il va y
avoir une réaction intéressante du côté
du pouvoir royal à paris des blogueurs
mais on va peut être revenir ça c'est
très intéressant aussi sur les chaînes
télégramme c'est à dire pas sur les
médias classiques russes qui depuis
quelques jours des blogueurs qui sont
loyaux d'habitude à vladmir poutine qui
depuis quelques jours critiques de façon
démentent ce qui s'est passé sur le plan
militaire dans le donbass alors cela
reproche à avaler un petit son caractère
belliqueux mais du côté des cercles
nationalistes aussi un bruno daroux les
reproches fusent envers vladimir poutine
accusé de ne pas recourir à la
conscription pour faire respecter la
russie il faut dire que les pertes du
week-end commence sans doute on
l'imaginait a pesé lourd oui parce que
ces pertes ont été assez importante et
puis plus globalement on estime autour
de 70 80 mille soldats russes qui ne
peuvent plus combattre un parmi
lesquelles il y aurait environ 15000
morts qu'ils le resteraient des blessés
ce qui fait beaucoup le problème de la
meilleure poutine c'est qu'en fait à la
différence de ce que demandent ces
cercles nationalistes il ne peut pas
nourrir doit vous interrompre événement
parce que la fleuve et la veillée
funèbre des butins en présence du
nouveau roi charles iii et de ses trois
frères et soeur la princesse anne sa
cadette 72 ans andrew 62 ans et edward
58 ans ils sont donc tous les quatre
réunies autour du cercueil de leur mère
pour lui témoigner cet hommage en écosse
en la cathédrale saint gilles vous qui
avez suivi tout au long de cette journée
ces événements c'est effectivement à la
fois très symbolique important parce que
la reine et s'est éteinte à balmoral
donc en sa résidence d'été mais
également parce que bien sûr les cos est
l'une des nations qui composent le
royaume uni l'une des lunes des quatre
nations oui absolument et là en fait
cette image est vraiment strictement
familial puisqu'il n'ya pas les petits
enfants il n'ya pas william et harry ce
sont uniquement vous l'avez dit les
quatre enfants de la reine dont le roi
charles iii qui viennent se recueillir
en cette cathédrale saint gilles à
edimbourg et c'est un peu le point
d'acmé si vous voulez de toute une
journée où les cos a été placé au centre
de ces cérémonies parce que la reine
effectivement est décédé à balmoral et
qu'on a vu que cette émotion des
écossais de nombreuses écossais en tout
cas vise vite de la vie la vie de la
reine nous allons donc observer un autre
tour à un instant de silence pour suivre
donc ce moment
et vous le voyez donc sur cette image
c'est donc et doivent le benjamin est le
roi charles bien sûr qui porte le kilt
comme il est de tradition en écosse vous
notiez and
hors antenne le prince andrew peut-être
compte tenu des déboires qu'il a
traversées dernièrement retirer
aujourd'hui la vie publique déchu de
tous ses titres ne se présente pas lui
en tenue militaire contrairement à ses
frères et soeurs on voit notamment la
princesse anne
oui ben je crois qu'il est ce sont les
instructions
étant donné le passé de ce qui s'est
passé avec un syndrome et ce qui est
intéressant d'air je trouve dans tout ce
qu'on vit depuis
le décès de la reine elizabeth ii
c'est de constater sans doute à quel
point ça avait été
organisée ses funérailles des deux
protocoles depuis très longtemps et la
reine concevoir la reine elle-même
justement qui
peut-être
avait non pas organiser tous
complètement mais avait souhaité
s'étendre à balmoral pour que justement
les cosses puisse vivre ce moment
qu'elle est en guinée
se dire que c'était très important a
cessé de livrer puisqu'on sait que les
dix jours précédant à peu près son état
de santé se dégrader fortement et que
notamment pour recevoir la nouvelle
première ministre il a été question
qu'elle rentre à londres et puis
finalement son état de santé apparemment
était déjà très dégradées quoi qu'il en
soit de toute façon balmoral c'était ses
quartiers d'été elle y passait trois
mois quasiment tous les ans donc il
était logique de la chine une propriété
personnelle des windsor win mais une
propriété personnes des windsor depuis
la reine victoria alors d'ailleurs on ne
sait pas on sait que c'est un endroit
que je chérissais la reine elizabeth
apparemment le prince charles lui
penserait plutôt dans un souci de faire
des économies et sa rentrée aussi en
prend de l'argent à faire de balmoral a
amusé ce qui évidemment j'aurais qu'ils
résident ray beaucoup moins souvent donc
là on peut voir que le cercueil
recouvert du drapeau royal écossais
parce que c'est le lion des gosses donc
on aperçoit la sur le
sur ce
support qui recouvre le cercueil avec
les quatre enfants autour alors qu'ils
sont pas face aux australiens en me
fondant du faubourg ça doit être ne
puisse pas coutume écossaise là on
aperçoit edwards alors effectivement
nous on a parlé la princesse anne
et les deux époux sont à 6 face au
cercueil les deux épouses évidemment
camilla voilà et sophie rhys-jones halal
l épouse du prince édouard puisqu'il est
le seul des quatre enfants ne pas avoir
dit vante d'avoir déversé absolument et
là vraiment c'est uniquement les enfants
il a été question un moment que oui
amélie
montrent aussi à edimbourg et puis
finalement en tout cas pour cette
cérémonie c'est vraiment la famille de
sang circule le plus resserrée du terme
on observe à rituel maintenant depuis
quatre ans une charge du protocole
extrêmement forte anne nivat ça ne
surprend pas bien sûr quand on connaît
le royaume uni ce protocole ils datent
de l'époque finalement d'avant les
moyens de communication modernes c'était
pour faire savoir au sujet du royaume
que la reine était morte et qu'un
nouveau roi donc lui lui succédait cette
tradition perdure
pour vous c'est un
une charge excessive sur année ou au
contraire elle se justifie encore
aujourd'hui
en tout cas c'est elle existe
visiblement personne en vie n'ait n'a
plus la modifier donc c'est en fait on a
l'impression que deux mondes
s'entrechoquent le l'ancien monde c'est
à dire que la reine elizabeth a régné
pendant si longtemps qu'effectivement
elle a pu elle-même voir constater tous
ces changements le temps médiatique
d'aujourd'hui qui n'est plus celui qui
était qu'il était précédemment etc mais
le protocole reste le même il n'a pas
changé et c'est finalement cette
stabilité que certains admirent et
d'autres critiques bien sûr dans le
monde aujourd'hui qu'ils admirent et je
pense hélas c'est effectivement la
permanence de l'institution qui permet
que depuis des siècles et dans ce monde
si instable voilà britanniques ont vent
de villars manon exprimé permanence à
apprécier ce qui est critiqué c'est la
légitimité même cette même principe
monarchique mais on en blessèrent ses
bailleurs a effectivement voilà tout un
débat mené quoi famille à l'abri
britannique a le droit de avec un succès
non démontré sa volée de l'opinion
publique puisqu'on loi d'ailleurs toutes
les télévisions elles ne font pas par
hasard choisi de retour en vient
d'ailleurs très largement ses affaires
c'est dû aussi à la personnalité
d'elisabeth ouais si on pense par
exemple à la monarchie espagnole juan
carlos qui est qui qui bénéficiaient
quand même d'un très grand soutien quand
il est revenu bon comme la fin a été peu
glorieuse tellement lui lègue à son
successeur le roi felipe 6 d'espagne une
institution très abîmé donc ça tient
aussi beaucoup à la manière dont la
personne humaine en fait incarne la
fonction est de ce point de vue on peut
dire qu'elle isabel ii a fait quasiment
un un sans faute le rayonnement tient à
la personnalité va remplir d'elisabeth
toutes les castes oui absolument
star d'une série de netflix
une association british avec les
britanniques qui peut faire ça
exactement mais qui est dont la dévotion
c'est vraiment le mot aux services
publics a marqué la vie entière
aujourd'hui qui en est capable donc il
ya quand même un respect vis-à-vis de la
reine elizabeth est comme un mystère de
la capacité qu elle avait joué dans à ne
jamais donner son avis à avoir toujours
ce sourire merveilleusement naturel au
coin des lèvres et ça je crois que
personne ne peut rester indifférent y'a
qu'a voir oui effectivement toutes les
télévisions américaines sont là les
journalistes américains étaient en deuil
noirs habillés de noir également dès le
moment de la nuit de son décès et même
la france très républicaine suit cet
événement total n'a pas à un mot
peut-être pour revenir sur notre sujet
ukraine russie mais mais en parler à
l'occasion un de cette veillée funèbre
et des obsèques des funérailles
d'elizabeth ii qui auront donc lieu
lundi prochain
le kremlin a fait savoir que l'indien
continue assisterait pas at il raté
d'après vous une occasion
je compte tenu du contexte politique vu
le contexte est un peu dessus je pense
que c'était quand même très difficile
pour lui d'apparaître dans une cérémonie
qui va être mondiale planétaire avec
quasiment tous les dirigeants de la
planète dont quand même les tous les
dirigeants occidentaux
comme pour le moment la négociation
n'est pas possible en tout cas la
négociation militaires et même politique
il ya juste des négociations n'a pas le
temps d'en parler pour la centrale de
zapruder jamais cessé des discussions
techniques très importante
sort était quand même très compliqué
pour lui d'apparaître c'est trop tôt à
la rigueur il a eu tout de même des mots
par communiqué jeudi dernier très forts
parlant d'une paire je crois irréparable
houéhou employant un synonyme bio mais
bien sûr mais c'est c'est la diplomatie
mondiale
venir poutine n'est pas en guerre contre
contre la grande bretagne il respecte le
cette période de deuil et la
personnalité justement comme nous venons
de caractériser d'elizabeth ii mais je
crois effectivement qu'il ait été
impossible que vladimir poutine vienne
physiquement lors à ses funérailles
parce que il est aujourd'hui devenu un
paria les médias occidentaux
on parle tous les jours
oui dans le monde hommes de lenteur dans
wii dans le monde occidental mais le
monde occidental qui est rangé du côté
de l'ukraine et qui donne des armements
des armes tous les jours et des
sanctions pour que juste et en
particulier leurs la russie ne gagne et
elle aurait été très compliqué au tout
juste sur quelques dossiers avec le
royaume une quipe à l'appoint lapointe
diplomatique et militaire que vous êtes
en train de dire c'est qu'en fait il n'a
fait que décliner une invitation qui lui
aurait de toute manière pas été fait
je ne sais pas si je ne sais pas notre
jeu je pense pas vraiment possible que
l'invitation
8 soit faite mais toute façon la
question se pose pas c'est la preuve il
a devancé l'appel et que au moment ça
c'est cette concomitance absolument
démente parfois des événements
médiatiques il se passe des choses sur
le terrain en ukraine militairement qui
sont très importantes au moment où nous
sommes dans ces journées de deuil qui
vont arriver jusqu'aux funérailles lundi
prochain de la reine elizabeth et
médiatiquement parlant c'est compliqué
de traiter des deux à la fois on le voit
d'ailleurs funérailles qui sont à la
fois des des moments à la fois comme ça
évidemment très symbolique de recueil
mostra des moments aussi presque
politique géopolitique elle a eu les
fédérés du général de gaulle par exemple
on peut aider les dirigeants de la
planète mais ça arrive assez peu souvent
mais là ce sera le cas où des sacs rabin
par exemple
funérailles et funambulisme c'est ce
qu'on a fait ce soir en mai lancée de
ces deux sujets houleux voire à propos
de sujets d'ailleurs sujets de la reine
le la famille royale qui quitte donc
cette cathédrale saint gilles
dans ce qui doit être l'entâme de sept
véhicules et motivé à vous le dis par
les épées c'est toute la nuit et
applaudi bien sûr par les écossais qui
auront que tel c'est quand même un port
un mot à dire sur leur appartenance au
port le mini puisque nicolas joel a
convoqué et nicolas seube john qui a
rencontré le roi charles iii qui a peut
être utilisée de son soft power pour lui
dire vous voyez en tout cas les écossais
en l'air d'aimer oui mais l'émotion et
la politique c'est pas la même chose
voilà c'est vrai merci ce sera le mot de
la fin dany va merci en avons été avec
nous aujourd'hui merci également à vos
bruno on se retrouve dans deux minutes
pour un nouveau journal dans par ligne
[Musique]